gross came out with an investment
outlook for his new employer Janus
Capital he is on the phone with us now
from Newport Beach California bill
welcome capitalism breaking down what do
you mean well thank you Stephanie I
didn't say it was about to break down I
said there was a danger of breaking down
and and the danger comes from this
distortion of monetary policy which
offers only zero percent interest rates
and some countries like Germany and
Switzerland very negative interest rates
investors require a return on their
money in order to take risk or to lend
their money to a to another party and to
the extent that they're negative or zero
then investors are savers ultimately and
simply stuff that money in a mattress as
opposed to invested in the economy so
these low interest rates have been too
low for too long and I think what the
Fed at least is going to do in six
months or so is to raise it up a little
bit to try and eliminate this distortion
bill if capitalism hasn't broken down
yet how would you describe the state of
capitalism right now well it certainly
is Morris Turek in it it's it's it's not
in great shape you know as we see in
Japan and in developed countries in your
land zero percent interest rates have
failed to generate any real growth and
and that typically has been the historic
result of lowering interest rates to
entice investment in the real economy so
capitalism at the moment has morphed
it's been distorted by quantitative
easing and the like and what an investor
in the real economy requires which is
what the Fed is ultimately pointing
towards is it an attractive return on
investment the problem with that is that
returns in the financial market are so
low that they've dragged down returns on
investment that cap rates and so on with
real estate and and other historically
lucrative types of returns are in the
four to five percent category and
there's simply too much risk relative to
what they've known in the past you right
in the investment outlook bill that
returns on equities will be quote
unquote supported what does that mean
well it means that the Japan will more
than likely most likely continue to to
implement their quantitative easing
policy which means they'll print lots of
money there more than we did over the
past several years it means that Draghi
will likely follow through with his
promise of a trillion dollars or so over
several years period of time even though
the United States for the moment is out
of the game and so the ECB and that in
the bill Jay have stepped in to take the
place of the United States and and money
and liquidity done a global basis is
being provided now so we see another
year of eleven twelve percent returns on
a stock market oh I don't think so in
the in the united states perhaps in in
japan and in countries where those
quantitative easing policies have
devalued and will continue to devalue
those currencies that makes stocks and
their local regions attractive but in
the united states where the dollar is
appreciating and being being devalued
against you know it's just the reverse
type of concept but i think ultimately
the global liquidity will will put a
floor under stock prices in the united
states but the the days of wine and
roses so to speak are over well will you
compare you tie the game of monopoly to
current Fed action how what Anna Janet
Yellen to jail but we know I did you go
around the board and monopoly and you
collect two hundred dollars it's
basically the being provided with more
cash and more liquidity to buy hotels
that that's basically what a central
bank does is they provide more money and
more credit in order to
it grows in the real economy the problem
is is that at the moment that that's not
happening that that money isn't going
into the real economy it's basically
going into the community chest or into
the into jail back to the banker and
then so monopoly as we knew it is this
changing as well because of the
inability of new cash two hundred
dollars per trip around the board to
generate sufficient real growth well in
1937 the Fed preemptively raised rates
and then we felt right back into a
recession do you believe looking back
Janet Yellen is a historian is that why
we haven't seen any move yet well I
think that's why we haven't seen any
through Bernanke's tenure he was very
aware of that you know a student in a
master of the depression and in terms of
what happened and in the effects of it
is not to suggest that Janet Yellen
isn't following in his path I think she
is and I think any central bank is aware
that when they raise interest rates much
like that taper tantrum several years
ago or suggest that they're going to
raise interest rates that it can have
precipitous consequences in a highly
levered economy which is what we have so
I I think she will raise interest rates
by 25 basis points in July or August but
it will be very slow like you know what
the forward curve the Treasury curve
suggests in the United States is that in
2019 februari they'll finally reach 2%
in terms of the Fed Funds rate and I
think that's about right but it'll take
us three or four years to get there bill
do you think between now and then the
10-year Treasury could test the 2012
2012 low yield of 139 to me Eric that
that's a stretch although and let me
just itch a tiny bit you know our
Treasuries are compared to german bonds
into UK gilts and
you know on a competitive global basis
it's true that yeah the current yield of
176 is much more attractive than the
yield on the 10-year Bund at 35 basis
points and so us rates will be dependent
upon where Germany goes and where the UK
goes and to the extent that German
interest rates you know they're negative
all the way out to six years so if their
tenure rate gets down to zero it goes
negative like it has in Switzerland then
you know our rates get dragged down as
well a final conclusion on debt though
is that those rates you know our
ultimate late so artificial that at some
point investors refuse to take debate
any further and so I think it's possible
that they go go lower from this point
but where they go and in terms of the
ultimate destination I think it's
dependent upon the conditions in
euroland and in Germany and elsewhere
bill our investors ignoring some of the
fundamental flaws in the US economy
right now simply because the US is doing
better than the rest of the world well I
think us is doing better you know we're
going to see a GDP number tomorrow i
believe and it's probably going to be a
three percent number although I point
out because of no inflation it'll
probably be a three percent nominal
number as well which is very important
because it's the nominal growth rate
which it determines profits and
determines debt service relative to
historical the norms so we're doing
better i think is the year winds on you
know and as that the boost from lower
gasoline prices dissipates that we move
back to it at two percent and maybe even
a one-percent economy by the end of the
year but having said that it's still
better than what we see elsewhere in
japan and your land bill if you're right
and investors so to speak in the bond
market stop taking the bait they refuse
to be beguiled by central bank policy
what happens to that money where does
that
go where does all the liquidity that
these very same central banks are
pumping into the system go into what
asset classes well it did did it go and
two separate areas Eric two tails some
investors would prefer simply like I
said to put it in a mattress and that's
a metaphor but they simply put it in a
bank because a zero percent interest
rate is as close to what they would be
taking on a 10-year treasury in terms of
its better risk and return other
investors as we've seen over the past
several years will go to the other tail
and will invest in equities under the
assumption that real growth ultimately
will be the result of these policies
what we've seen so far as is that
certainly has been the case in the
United States and so stocks rallied
significantly during quantitative easing
in the light but you know if real growth
fails to continue to demonstrate it its
strength like it has in the past few
quarters then those tail investors that
are dependent upon growth for equities
will be likely to move you know catch to
the running at a time I just want to ask
you before we go now that you are at
janus not pimco do you feel that you
have more freedom to really express your
thoughts and tell us what you think oh
not tell you what I think I have more
freedom to move because it's certainly a
smaller I would recognize that and this
is the ability to move in markets is is
different but I've always told you what
I thought